♪ ♪
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: SINCE KEVIN HART
BAILED FROM THE OSCARS, THE
AWARDS SHOW WAS EXPERTLY SEEKING
NEW OPTIONS INCLUDING GOING
WITHOUT A HOST AT ALL.
THINK ABOUT IT.
THE OSCARS LOOKED AROUND AT ALL
THE POSSIBILITIES IN THEIR OWN
MORALLY PURE INDUSTRY DECIDED
YOU KNOW WHAT.
IT'S NOT WORTH IT.
WE ARE ALL JERKS, CLOWNS,
SINNERS, BIGOTS AND PIGS.
OF COURSE WE ARE PETRIFIED OF
THE MOB, MEANING THEY ARE
ACTUALLY HUMAN.
JUST AS EVERY HUMAN HAS A SKILL
OR TALENT, WE ALL HAVE A PAST OR
A LIFE.
ONE WORTH MORE THAN A TWEET.
BUT FOR SOME, A SIMPLE DIGNIFIED
APOLOGY WILL NEVER BE ENOUGH.
THE MORAL MAJORITY IS NOW THE
MOB MORALITY AND FORGIVENESS IS
VIEWED AS AN ACCESSORY TO EVIL.
AND THE OSCARS IS RESPONDING THE
WAY EVERYONE DOES NOW, TO BE SO
GUN SHY ABOUT THAT SOCIAL MEDIA
FALLOUT THAT THEY JUST GIVE UP
AND GIVING.
NO ONE WANTS TO SHARE THE RISK.
SO NOTHING TOO EDGY AND HUMANS
ARE JUST THAT IN THE FACE OF
UNFORGIVING HORDES.
AFTER DECADES OF FILLING THE
HOSTING POSITION, HUMANS NEED
NOT APPLY.
SO THEN HOW ABOUT THE CHESS
PLAYING COMPUTER?
IT'S COLD, FACELESS AND NEVER
TOLD A JOKE OFFENSIVE OR
OTHERWISE EVER, MUCH LIKE SETH
MEYERS.
OR HOW ABOUT A DRONE,
SIGNIFICANT DROP IN CRUDE JOKE
FROM ON HIGH AND THEN COMPLETELY
DISAPPEAR?
LIKE MICHELLE WOLF.
HOWEVER THEY PICK, THEY WILL BE
HOSTING THE SHOW FROM UNDER A
ROCK OR UNDER THE ROCK.
UNLESS THEY FIND SOMEONE WITH
GUTS WHO'S NOT AFRAID.
WHO COULD THAT BE?
THAT'S MY CHOICE.
>> Dana: I WILL TAKE THE RISK.
>> Greg: I WILL TAKE THE RISK.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO TAKE THE
RISK.
EVEN THE OSCARS TO ME IS LIKE
ANY BUSINESS, THEY ARE LIKE WE
DON'T WANT ANY TROUBLE.
THEY STEP AWAY AND THEN THEY
JUST KIND OF --
>> Dana: TALK ABOUT PICKING UP
YOUR BALL AND GOING HOME.
THAT WOULD MEAN WE WOULDN'T HAVE
TO DO A SHOW ABOUT THE OSCARS TO
TALK ABOUT MOVIES WE HAVEN'T
WATCHED RATES FOR WORK THAT'S
TRUE.
WHENEVER WE DO A SEGMENT, WE
PRETEND WE HAVE -- WE DON'T
PRETEND.
>> Dana: WEEKS AGO JOY BEHAR
WAS FRUSTRATED WITH THE COUNTRY
MUSIC AWARDS BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
MAKE IT POLITICAL.
YOU CAN'T SAY ANYTHING
OFFENSIVE.
YOU CAN SEE SOMETHING POLITICAL
AS LONG AS IT'S OFFENSIVE TO
HALF THE COUNTRY.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
THAT'S THE POINT I SHOULD'VE PUT
IN THE MONOLOGUE.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS A GOOD
MONOLOGUE.
YOU SHOULD TAKE MARTY'S OFF TO
REFRESH YOURSELF.
COMING OFF --
THIS ONE IS REALLY GOOD.
PEOPLE IN FILM AND ART IN
HOLLYWOOD, THESE ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE THE CREATIVE PEOPLE WITH
EXPRESSION AND NOT AFRAID TO
TAKE RISKS.
THEY ARE THE MOST UPTIGHT
SQUARES EVER.
THEY RUINED INTO THE OSCARS.
THEY DID THE SAME THING WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS'
DINNER.
IT GOT TOO EDGY FOR THEM.
THEY BLEW IT, AND NOW THERE'S A
HISTORIAN UP THERE INSTEAD OF A
COMEDIAN.
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS IS
LITERALLY RUINING COMEDY.
HAS ANYONE EVER SAID THAT
BEFORE?
>> Greg: I THINK YOU JUST
COINED IT.
MORGAN.
>> Morgan: I AM GLAD YOU
REMEMBERED MY NAME.
>> Greg: I LOOKED DOWN.
I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH NAMES ON
LIVE TELEVISION.
>> Morgan: I AM ON YOUR SHOW A
LOT.
>> Greg: AND I HAVE A SHRINE
IN MY OFFICE.
>> Morgan: I WAS ON YOUR SHOW.
THE LADY AT THE OTHER END OF THE
CAMERA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: BUT YOU'RE ALSO ON ON
"SPECIAL REPORT" TOO.
PIXAR, HOLOGRAM, THE WHOLE
THING.
CREATE A HOST.
>> Morgan: I DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE OSCARS.
I WANT THE OSCARS TO CONTINUE
BECAUSE I LOVE THE FASHION
SEGMENT.
I WATCH THE OSCARS BECAUSE I AM
SO GIRLY.
I LOVE SEEING THE WOMEN COMING
OUT IN GALLONS.
I LOVE THE EARRINGS IN THE
FASHION AND THE HAIR.
>> Greg: WHY DOES IT HAVE TO
BE GIRLS?
>> Morgan: I AM SAYING THAT I
LIKE WATCHING THE GIRLS.
>> Greg: WHY CAN'T MEN WEAR
THE DRESSES?
WHY ARE YOU SO CIS NORMATIVE?
>> Morgan: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT MEANS.
>> Greg: WHAT BOTHERS ME IS
THAT WE ARE WITNESSING THE DEATH
OF FORGIVENESS.
YESTERDAY YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
THE HEISMAN TROPHY WINNER.
KEVIN HART.
HE ALREADY APOLOGIZED AND THEN
HAD TO APOLOGIZE AGAIN.
WHERE ARE THE COMEDIANS?
>> Juan: YOU SAID KEVIN HART
BAILED.
I DON'T THINK HE BAILED ON THEM.
I THINK THEY WERE VERY RELUCTANT
TO DEFEND KEVIN HART.
IT'S NOT GOING TO FEED THE
SOCIAL MEDIA FRENZY.
>> Greg: BUT HE APOLOGIZED
AGAIN.
>> Juan: I THINK IT WAS
SINCERE IN THE SENSE THAT HE
SAID HE EVOLVED.
LOTS OF PEOPLE HAVE EVOLVED ON
THIS QUESTION.
SO WHAT'S THE BIG DEAL HERE?
BUT THE WAY THE TWITTER
SOCIAL MEDIA UNIVERSE WORKS IS
IT'S AN ENDING AND IT IS
UNFORGIVING.
BUT I WILL SAY IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR IDEA THAT WE GIVE MAX
HEADROOM THE JOB --
>> Greg: WOULD THAT BE THE
HIGHEST RATED EVER?
>> Juan: IT WOULD BE.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A
COMPUTER GRAPHIC.
I SUSPECT, HAVE THE PERSON
DRESSED IN UNUSUAL WAYS AND SAY
EDGY THINGS.
WE COULD GO BACK TO LIKE REDD
FOXX AND WHO IS THAT GREAT
COMEDIAN?
MITCH.
WE WERE AT THE REAGAN LIBRARY
THE OTHER DAY, OUR FRIEND
BRET BAIER AND CHRIS WALLACE AND
I.
THEY HAVE NOW REAGAN AS A
HOLOGRAM.
LIKE MICHAEL JACKSON.
THEY HAVE REAGAN AS A HOLOGRAM.
>> Morgan: WHAT ABOUT HOWARD
STERN?
>> Greg: THAT WOULD BE FUN.
>> Jesse: NEVER SURVIVE.
>> Morgan: I LISTEN TO HIS
RADIO SHOW ALL THE TIME.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT YOU WERE SO
GIRLY A MINUTE TO GO.
>> Morgan: I AM.
I LIKE THE FASHION.
>> Juan: LISTENING TO HOWARD
STERN?
>> Morgan: YOU CAN BE FEMININE
AND STILL LIKE HOWARD STERN.
>> Juan: FOR A WOMAN TO HEAR
THIS KIND OF TALK.
>> Dana: SHE HAS A WIDE RANGE
OF INTERESTS.
>> Morgan: I HAVE HEARD
SAILORS SAY A LOT WORSE.
>> Greg: I THINK WE NEED TO
BRING FORGIVENESS BACK.
>> Dana: MY POINT WAS THREE
WEEKS AGO WE HAD DAN CRENSHAW ON
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" AND
EVERYONE SAID THAT'S THE MODEL
FOR HOW WE SHOULD HANDLE IT.
>> Juan: TODAY THERE WAS A
CASE IN TEXAS.
A GUY ATTACKED A WOMAN AND THEN
THE JUDGE SAYS 400 BUCKS AND
SOME COMMUNITY SERVICE.
THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
I DON'T THINK I AM A HARD MAN
BUT GOODNESS GRACIOUS.
>> Dana: WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE SAME THING.
HE WAS ACCUSED OF A CRIME.